last night was absolutely amazing you
are fantastic and I have to say you
looked absolutely gorgeous so sexy on
stage looked amazing how does it feel
it's the next day now is there a sense
of relief now that you've done the
opening night oh yes yeah great
satisfactions even a probably I think
more the feeling satisfaction yeah I'm
satisfied that you know we we met the
deadline there's always a crunch at the
end and it's so I guess it's just it's a
it's a great feeling it's very rewarding
yeah to get to the point where I can
present it and feel so satisfied with
the result you know I mean and with it
was it's everything that I imagined is
more more than I imagined it's the first
time playing in this room and I've seen
a lot of shows here yeah I felt like it
was mine for that moment
yeah it's leading up to that moment to
opening night what were you going
through was their anxiety butterflies
were you ready was there a different
type of confidence because you were part
of the production there was I had more
confidence I have more confidence I
think because I am more involved it's
sort of like when you were involved from
the very very beginning
you're so studied everything every
department so well mm-hmm that by the
time you're ready to present what like
let's say you had to make a presentation
yeah yourself you're really prepared you
know every element you know everything
that's going on around you he there's no
mystery there and that makes you feel
more secure and more
more confident in the process yeah you
know and I I was prepared I'm more
prepared than I've ever been for any
other show just because I I was involved
in the fashion you look so fat every
single piece was absolutely amazing were
you worried about any wardrobe
malfunctions no I don't you know for me
I'm very very serious about comfort and
function mm-hmm I don't want to I don't
want any distractions I don't want
things poking me I don't want things
falling I don't want things getting in
my way I have to just focus on
performing on singing on the staging and
the connection with the audience being a
performer mm-hmm so the fun part of the
fashion is getting the the styling and
the design together and then there's the
practical side where I know that you
know the zipper is gonna work or
whatever so I feel confident when I go
out there that it's all gonna work
that's good yeah and I'm getting a
little emotional being here right now
after last night and seeing your stage
and being here with this moment with you
I mean you know you're an inspiration to
so many people and you show that hard
work anything is possible
so if we're reacting that way what does
this chapter mean in your journey I do
think that I proved to myself all the
time I think it's necessary to do that
I'll want to I'm never I'll never get
tired of living the experience of you
know the harder you work the figures of
rewards mm-hmm this is just so much true
to that so I perfect it myself all the
time you know the more I put into
something the more I get out of it and
the more fun I have and also I think the
more the more challenge the more you
learn right I'm so I know so much more
now after this first experience of being
so hands-on with directing this
production that
I want to do more and I've got you know
I've got more experience now than ever
before and and I feel that growth is
everything you need to wake up in the
morning yeah looking I wake up every
morning looking for challenge I'm not
looking for trouble but you do also
become a better problem-solver as well
you know the more you do these things so
I don't think this is gonna I'm at a
point in my life right now where I feel
like there's not gonna be enough life
for me to really do everything I want to
do now hmm because I so many things have
opened up for me in the last couple of
years just by being proactive and
getting my confidence back obviously my
voice was a huge part of that taking on
the challenge to get my voice back now I
feel like it's endless like the
possibilities are endless you even say
keep your chin up while you're
performing yesterday which was so
beautiful after you have to remind
yourself all the time so and there was a
performance that was so beautiful when
you dedicated to the late Prince yeah
forever for always and the story is that
he approached you about doing an album
with you I'm curious what was that last
conversation you have with Prince well
the last conversation I had about the
album was quite a few years earlier and
I wasn't ready to make an album yet and
I my voice wasn't there I was I was just
going through my divorce and we stayed
in touch over text in the phone all
those years and then but very close to
him passing we were we had met in person
backstage at one of his shows and it was
just very personal and calm and sweet
and really more just about being friends
you know that anything and it you know
it he's just he was such a gentle sweet
person and any of the intimidation that
I had felt of meeting an icon that I
revered so highly dissipated when we met
him you know actually long earlier when
we were already in phone conversations
but when we had met in person at
mythologist personally personally I'm
getting the chills yeah it's just
thinking and you know I you know the
person that he did he recorded forever
and for always so I his version is so
great and now that's really when it's
realest thing to that inspired me to
make the song purple and personal very
personal and then you saying man I feel
like a woman everyone goes crazy the
fans go extra crazy is it one of your
favorite songs to perform oh yeah oh man
I feel like woman is really the spirit
of my liberate itself at the core mm-hmm
as a woman and I enjoy I feel that it
liberates a lot of people and it has
liberated a lot of people in the sense
of self-expression mm-hmm and there's a
huge reward in that and writing a song
like that yeah and seeing the effect
roll out and I so I see it every night
yeah when I perform it so I relived that
joy every time I do it
yeah you know what's so great next year
2020 it is gonna be kick-ass women in
Vegas there's you Kelly Clarkson Lady
Gaga and now apparently Beyonce is going
to be doing a mean what does it mean
that she'll be part of this roster oh I
mean it's incredible I think anybody
that plays Las Vegas I mean we've all
played less because we've all gone
through with tours but if you're doing a
long-term scenario here you are that is
like a badge of honor that is
a you know a peak in one's career it is
a privilege privilege and it's a
privilege to see you today so thank you
for inviting me and seeing the show
yesterday thank you